i fully support it the these are the
best athletes in the world and plenty of
these guys if they had gone in a
different direction would be among the
elites in other endeavors yeah i i want
to see what he can do yeah i i'm like
i'm really interested i can't wait
actually it's that's one of those things
where is it going to be on tv
i mean because it's 4 30 p.m eastern on
nbc oh it is on saturday i wasn't
listening i was getting ready for my
draft here so damn i'll be watching i
just want to see
where he stacks up and that kind of
event because i'm with you i'm one of
those guys mike that i've i've had these
conversations yeah i mean people like
tyreek hill and odell beckham jr and dk
metcalf i've always been one to say like
in high school if they decided they
wanted to be in the olympics i think
they'd be in the final heat of the the
olympics 100 meter dash i do
uh so it'd be interesting you know like
i had a chance to throw to justin gatlin
one year remember justin gatlin the 100
meter sprinter and all of that hey he
was fast there's no doubt there's no
doubt
but i'll just say
and again i know it's on the football
field he wasn't as fast as joey galloway
or chris johnson who i was on the
football field with a lot and that's
where it's going to be interesting and
i'm excited to see this
well and and also you know the sprinters
are fairly muscular but dk metcalf shows
up what i know right you run and hide it
right
go ahead you can just you you will
concede to dk metcalf so that'll be fun
again 4 30 p.m eastern on nbc on sunday
trivia question for chris to determine
the first pick in today's draft guys
that we would peg for an olympic event
aaron rodgers is the only player in
history with 400 touchdown passes and
fewer than 100 interceptions who's the
only other player with 200 or more
touchdown passes and fewer than 100
interceptions
well the greatest touchdown to
interception ratio quarterbacks our
league has ever seen
is rogers
brady and russell wilson brady's been
playing so i'm gonna go russell wilson
[Music]
um thank you very much thank you very
much thank you very much
all right the first pick now that you've
done your research when you otherwise
should have been listening i know sorry
nbc i it's 4 30 that track meet
um i guess the first one that jumps out
to me
i'm gonna go i want to see my homes
throw the javelin that's that's the
number one thing mahomes throwing the
javelin if you want to what i mean the
guy can throw it over those there
mountains over there look at that i mean
so i want to see how how long can he
throw that damn long stick through the
air if he could throw a football in the
yard how long can he throw that damn
thing he's got go go gadget gumby arms
and
uh it seems like he can throw any object
as far as he wants so mahomes to the
javelin was the first thing that popped
in my to my brain
i've got some creative ideas i'm gonna
save for later for now though since
baseball is back as an olympic sport it
had a hiatus why would you not want
kyler murray on the diamond for team usa
so that one's a simple one to me that
one's not fun i got a couple fun ones i
don't want to oversell it but kyler
murray on the u.s men's baseball team
gold medal guaranteed looking you stir
in the pot already look hey kyler you
don't need to go to off season with
arizona go play baseball go to the
olympics uh no i hear you that would i
would i would like to see kyla murray
play baseball anyways that'd be fun to
watch um all right my next one um
i mean aaron donald has to be in some
event i i don't know
roman wrestling right i mean it could be
wrestling it could be power lifter but
really ultimately come on aaron rod i
mean aaron donald in like
a tight fit outfit with the ball the
shot put under i mean he looks like he's
made for that to put the shot put right
there and spin really fast and be really
explosive and throw a heavy ball as far
as you can i mean aaron donald is yeah
he he he's made for that i mean he
really looks like the the build of those
guys in the olympics i'd like to see
that it's got to be some it's got to be
some kind of wrestling it's got and then
greco-roman it was always just such a
cool name i never understood it but i
loved saying greco-roman wrestling and i
have a feeling aaron donald would
dominate even if he doesn't know what it
is either yeah figure it out and he's
strong enough to prevail in whatever the
athletic endeavor would be next one for
me um
i'm going to go
devin white in equestrian because didn't
we see him running that horse around
tampa bay's yeah
they won the super bowl he did you know
jumper now the horse better be strong
because you're carrying a fairly large
guy jumping over things but uh yeah you
get a good horse that can do all that
with devon white on the back then uh off
we go yeah uh that i i that would be
that'd be cool yeah yeah he'd be he'd be
the biggest damn equestrian rider out
there that's for sure muscles everywhere
popping out everything like that yeah
that'd be better be a strong horse
no doubt about it um
well
i i tend to think through the lens of a
quarterback right and i mean when i
think of the olympics and especially i'm
thinking summer olympics here a lot more
it's just
you know archery aaron rodgers
just hitting targets
boom boom boom boom oh there's a picture
of guten coast boom i shot it
[Music]
i'm joking of course but yes i can
picture him being unreal in that event
with his quick release his eye
you know his hand-eye coordination is of
course as good as you've ever seen
whether you watch him play football or
golf it's pretty damn special
yeah i would definitely not volunteer to
stand with an apple on my head for aaron
rodgers that's for sure oh yeah don't
worry he'll miss on that one
it's just a
the apple would survive
i got a few other ones um
and look winter olympics uh bill
belichick curling just because it's all
angles and
momentum oh right he'll like yeah he'll
have ernie on the side
tell me how i should shave the ice
every match uh
i'll i'll go
and you said mahomes already i was
thinking my homes as a tennis player
would be awesome just the way he moves
on the football field yeah uh i'll but
i'll i'll go with nahim hines gymnastics
given the celebrations that we saw from
him a couple of times this year he's got
that great backflip so uh you know you
do the pommel horse or something like
that i think with enough training
he'd be potentially olympic level i i
hear you there i i had the same thought
with tyree kill where i went like with
tyree killed i wrote down 100 meter but
i also wrote down gymnastics too same
thing i mean we see him doing the flips
and i can picture him running across
that mat and doing seven flips and
popping in the air and doing that type
of stuff so
i had a similar thought there with a
similar type of athlete
so who is the 4x100 dream relay of nfl
players that that's a good question
who is the four
i mean i'm putting tyrique at the the
the anchor right i think i'm gonna
make him the last guy i think he's the
fastest guy in football
okay
terry mclaurin
dk metcalf
who else we missing who is another name
that jumps out to you
i mean jalen ramsey john ross john ross
not a very good football player but he
ran the fastest 40 at the combine he's
your guy out of the gates he's your guy
from the standing start or the you know
whatever they do whatever they get in
the blocks
he's in that conversation you're right i
feel like there's somebody else we're
missing with great speed that maybe is
in this conversation there um
but i think those those are the names
that that make a lot of sense are we
missing a running back that can maybe be
in the the group there i mean dalvin
cook could be one of those guys you
might want to put at the start of the
box too like i think you know you're
right john ross but like let's pick star
players like star guys that like really
are like you have a reason you want to
win or do you want to sell jerseys well
yeah i want to sell jerseys no okay but
you're right henry ruggs henry
right
right so ruggs has to be on there with
tyreke
with dk
and damn
are we gonna am i gonna you're gonna go
i'm gonna put terry mclaurin i mean
terry mccorman to me is one of the
fastest guys in football nobody catches
him once he gets out in the open uh but
is there anybody on the defensive side
of the ball we're missing there that's
worthy of being in that conversation too
pete says scotty miller says he should
run all four legs
i think we hit hollywood brown
hollywood brown is another one to
consider yeah so no doubt it would be
fun it would be fun it'd be great to see
how they would do against the uh the
real 4x100
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports